Are you alright?
I'm alright.
Alright, I'm alright,
are you alright?
I'm happy as you can be
in these crazy times.
It's Season 2 of Hart to Heart.
Me and my celebrity friends
are back for more.
Get ready, cause
it's about to get real.
An Asian person can affect
western culture.
I tweeted, "Hey, Marvel,
how about an Asian American superhero?"
Are you in awe
of what you've been able
to accomplish?
I have total belief in myself.
It's like a peacock,
like spreading his wings.
A lot of years of ohh.
Mhm.
I thought the pearly gates of
Hollywood were gonna open.
I don't think people understand that.
You asked for the cheese plate.
I love food.
You've got to have crazy gas.
Ha ha ha ha!
So I'm playing Joey Ramone
in this, like, music thing.
It's like the biggest
role of my life.
Vulture's like,
"I want to be sedated during
his performance."
It's something to see, as a
young guy, trying to achieve
the success that you have
already achieved.
You ain't that ******* young.
- I'm going to edit this out.
- I love you.
Alright, that's enough.